[Music]
the climax and indeed partial
culmination of ursula k leguin's third
earth sea novel the farthest shore
is taking place in the second to last
chapter chapter 12 the dry land in this
confrontation between ged or sparrowhawk
and his companion aaron or lebanon
depending on whether we're using their
use or true names
and this
mage
cobb that's his use name he no longer
remembers what his actual true name is
who has opened up a door
that has caused the crisis and indeed
catastrophe and there's a very
interesting reversal that is going to
take place
here in this chapter because cobb
confronts ged and lebanon and says ah
you know i'm i'm the one who's beyond
all of you there's even a point where he
tells them that
i'm the the only one who truly is you
have no name only i exist right and this
is
in some respects
delusion and bravado and get cuts right
through it
prior to that when
sort of like a super villain revealing
his his
terrible plan
cobb tells them what was going on he
says would you like to know how i did
what i did and he says
i rewove this these spells from the
pelnish lore and made a spell the
greatest spell that has ever been made
the greatest and the last and in doing
so
he dies
and he says alone of all men in time i
am lord of the true lands and the door i
opened is not only here but in the minds
of the living in the depths and unknown
places of their being where we are all
one in the darkness this explains how
all of these people including aaron
could have cobb sort of you know
gesturing to them come along with me how
they could see him as this kingly figure
and he tells them
i opened a door that has been shut
since the beginning of time and now i
come freely to this place and freely
return to the world of the living so he
did something he changed the very fabric
of reality he opened a door perhaps
created a door right between what the
two realms that of the living and the
dead and when get asked him well where
are you he says well i'm in between and
by that there's not a third realm but
he's able to go between the living and
the dead
now this sounds really you know
terrible but also on cobb's part awesome
and then when ged talks to him cobb
admits what the real
situation is
again tells him i would give you life if
i could cub but i can't you're dead
and then cobb says you cannot give me
death
no one can ever set me free i open the
door between the worlds and i
cannot shut it
so
this is an admission of he he did
something that was incredible
but on the other hand he's not really
the master
the lord the immortal one that he
pretends to be something is
greater than him something is compelling
him
he says
no one can shut it it will never be shut
again it draws it draws me
i must come back to it i must go through
it and come back here into the dust and
cold in silence it sucks at me and sucks
at me i cannot leave it i cannot close
it
so here he's admitting that what he
opened up
is not really subject to him he is
subject to
it so as grand as his power is there's
something else that has greater power
than him it compels it determines it
necessitates him but this is why it's a
crisis and a catastrophe i mean ged
might be willing to intervene to help
out somebody stuck in a situation like
that in particular since ged himself
monkeyed around with life and death and
opening up these sort of doors in the
past himself as he's admitted
but there's a catastrophe for earth sea
and cob knows this he says
it will suck all the light out of the
world in the end all the rivers will be
like the dry river there is no power
anywhere that can close the door that i
opened
very strange was the mixture of despair
and vindictiveness terror and vanity in
his words
and his voice
so cabba's is now opening to get an air
in the possibility that
you know maybe they can get him to
at least give them information and that
is what they try to do they say you need
to show us where this door is
and um
ged says though you chose despair
remember we have not done so take us
there
and then cobb says i will not and aaron
says you will
and he says who are you my name is
lebanon
god says you who call yourself king do
you not know who this is
and then cobb says basically there's
there's no point to this
uh he is dead you are dead you cannot go
back there's no way out you are caught
here
and then um
cobb takes off running and and they
follow him
up the dry river there's a
interesting description here
they they go upstream
and aaron came sword and handed after
him dead soon aaron had out distanced
his companion and the light was very
faint
much interrupted by the boulders and
turnings of the riverbed but the sound
of cobbs going the sense of his presence
ahead was guide enough
they come to a place
he says the final narrowing into the
banks
and then he catches up to cobb there in
the cliff
there was a black hole the source of the
dry river and cobb says
this is the place now notice what he he
does cobb seems to have forgotten
his despair now he tells them
hey
you want to join me you you can become
part of this he says
uh here we go
this is the place you seek see it there
you can be reborn
all you need to do is follow me you will
live immortally we shall be kings
together
so notice what he's offering you and me
aren't and maybe ged we can all rule
over this
you can be with me and it's as if he's
forgotten
exactly what he said you know just a few
minutes before which is
i'm not really in charge here and i i
don't have control over this so this is
not a great idea and what ends up
happening instead is ged
uses his power uses up his power
in order to close this up so gad
first aaron says
let it be shut
you looked at the dry dark spring head
the mouth of dust the place where a dead
soul crawling into earth and darkness
was born again dead abominable it was to
him and he said in this harsh voice
struggling with deadly sickness let it
be shut ged says it will be shut
and light blazed up now from his hands
and face as if he were a star fallen on
earth in that endless night before him
the dry spring the door yawned open it
was wide and hollow but whether deep or
shallow there was no telling there was
nothing in it for the light to fall on
for the eye to see it was void though it
was neither life or dark neither life
nor death it was nothing it was a way
that led nowhere ged raised up his hands
and spoke with all the skill of his
life's training and with all the
strength of his fierce heart ged strove
to shut that door to make the world
whole once more and under his voice and
the command of his shaping hands the
rocks drew together painfully trying to
be whole to meet
but at the same time the light weakened
and weakened dying out from his hands
and from his face dying out from his you
staff until only a little glimmer of it
hung there by that faint light iron saw
the door was nearly closed and he will
indeed close it he will say be thou made
whole with his staff he draws lines of
fire across the gate of rocks a figure
the roon ognen the rune of ending which
closes roads and is drawn on coffin lids
and then there was no gap or void place
among the boulders the door was shut
dead succeeds
in doing so he exhausts all of his power
all of his magic and is left with
nothing
although not completely with nothing
because he will do one other thing
prior to this
cobb seeing what's happening
attacks get
he tries to strangle him
lebanon
cuts him across the neck with his sword
and there's actually the i should read
this description this is quite good um
aaron raised up the sword of sarada and
brought the blade down straight and hard
on the bowed neck between the matted
hair the living spirit has weight in the
world of the dead and the shadow of his
sword has an edge the blade made a great
wound severing cobb's spine black blood
left out till
lit by the sword zone light but there is
no good in killing a dead man and cobb
was dead years dead the wound closed
swallowing its blood the blind man stood
up very tall groping out with his long
arms at aaron his faith writhing with
rage and hatred as if he had just now
perceived who his true enemy and rival
was
so horrible to see was this recovery
from a death blow this inability to die
more horrible than any dying that a rage
of loathing swelled up an r in a berserk
fury and swinging the sword again he
struck with it a full terrible downward
blow cobb fell with skulls split open
and face masked with blood yet aaron was
upon him at once to strike again before
the wound could close to strike until he
killed
ged then closes
the thing
the doorway
and
after that
ged tells cobb this
by the word that will not be spoken
until times end i summon thee by the
word that was spoken at the making of
things i now release thee go free
and bending over the blind man god
whispered in his ear
cobb stood up
he looked about him slowly with seeing
eyes he looked at aaron and then at ged
he spoke no word but gazed at them with
dark eyes there was no anger in his face
no hate no grief
slowly he turned and went down the
course of the dry river and soon was
lost to sight
that is the end of the person who almost
destroyed the world he becomes
one of the dead ged releases him into
that now that this
horrible damage that was done the gap
the
void the
doorway between the worlds has been
closed by the
sacrifice of all of god's power
and that is
how the
hole in existence
ends up being closed it's not the end of
the story
but it's the
end of the crisis
you